tu es avec beaucoup d'émotion et de
tristesse que nous apprenons donc la
disparition de rue du président félix
chollon à qui était président de la
ligue de football
juste après charles st cyr l'arrivée
du président ursule et ce qu'il faut
retenir du président en solo c'est sûr
ce sont des faits marquants sait déjà
son combat pour l'adhésion de la ligue
de football de mardi à l'union
caribéenne de football et si je ne me
trompe pas c'est sous sa présidence donc
que la ligue de football intègre l'union
caribéenne de football et puis il est
aussi l'un des précurseurs de la 18e à
la concacaf alors c'est un projet qu'il
n'a pas pu mener à son terme sous sa
présidence et je crois savoir que sa
démission
de la ligne de football j'ai ensuite à
la refuse de la fédération française de
notre intégration sous sa présidence et
puis comme je vous disais je crois que
c'est un humaniste
j'ai eu plaisir à le côtoyer puisqu'il
est toujours bon il là il avait été
éloigné donc du monde du football et
puis le président sanha le perron
l'avait rappelé nous lui avions confiée
mission puisque c'est l'actuel président
de la commission régionale de l'éthique
et de la morale sportive donc voilà donc
une commission qu'il présidait avec nous
jusqu il y à peu près deux ans et quand
nous faisions appel à l' michaud des
sujets sensibles de valeurs d'éthique
voilà donc il faut retenir sa de ce
président cholot un vrai humaniste la
disparition d'un grand homme du football
martiniquais